With more than 1.8 billion cans of soft drinks sold daily, and nearly 48% of Americans
Drink at least a glass of soda water a day. Easy to say that many of us like
Sugary drinks. But what happens to our bodies and minds if we drink soda water only?
When the drink enters your mouth, high acidity in it leads to enamel erosion in the teeth,
The microorganisms in your teeth begin to feed on sugar
Leading to decay. When the box is finished, you have consumed more than 46 grams of sugar.
The receptors on your tongue feel this and send a message to the cortex of your brain
"I want more," he says. A week later
By drinking 8 glasses of water recommended by cola you will have
Consumed more than 5432 extra calories. This is one of the biggest associated health problems
Drink soft drinks is: overweight.
⅕ Weight gain is estimated in the United States between 1977-2007
Attributable to soft drinks. In addition, Yale researchers found that when people drink
Soft drinks, they also consume more calories, and because they simply do not calculate exactly
Calories added to their drinks. Moreover, corn syrup is high fructose
It is the primary local in soft drinks not digested in our bodies the same way
Other sugars are digested. Increases the fat of the liver, thereby increasing the risk of cardiovascular disease
Insulin hormones and leptin are not active. These hormones are the body that feel
And prevents excessive eating. Infection with insulin also increases the risk of infection
Diabetes. Overall, studies suggest that reducing the amount of sugar in the beverage may
Prevents one million excess obesity
So, should we switch to diet drinks? Surprisingly, there is still a link between
Industrial sweeteners and obesity also. Tests found that the sweet taste
Whether it is real sugar or artificial sweeteners, increases appetite, not to mention
That many dieters allow themselves to eat more with their knowledge that they have been reduced
Calories saying, "Since I drink soda diet, I can take big fried potatoes with burgers"
But soft drinks can make us thirsty. The cellulite is a protective covering on the ends of our chromosomes
Which shorten with time. It turned out that the rate of its shortness at
A person who takes 600 ml of soda a day is the same person as a smoker
So what would happen if I drank two liters of soda a day? Well a woman has done it for over 16 years
Until the hospital was admitted at age 31. Although her family history is free of heart disease
She suffered from palpitations and fainting spells, and tests showed that she had severe deficiency
In potassium, where fructose and caffeine cause loss of potassium with urine
And diarrhea. Luckily our bodies have a wonderful ability to recover, once they have stopped drinking
Potassium levels returned to normal levels and most of the symptoms began to disappear
Need more science?
Here is a playlist with the latest sections you can watch.
If you do not want to miss any of our clips simply go to our channel on your computer
Through the YouTube application and click the small bell that will in turn turn alerts to our sections
YouTube will send you a message every time we launch one of our clips
Participate in the channel for more of our weekly scientific sections!